we've got some interesting questions
this week let's start with Leila who
wrote in hey how should couples split
expenses and bills what's fair alright I
have some thoughts on this and I don't
think my thoughts on this are
controversial but I have been wrong in
the past so let's let's jump into this
let's imagine you have a couple that
does not earn the same salary right each
person in the couple earns a different
salary so what does it make sense to do
in terms of splitting expenses and bills
I believe that expenses that are not
based on usage should be split in
proportion to income and what I mean by
usage is rent for example rent is an
amount that is fixed every single month
you might have a you know $1,500 rent if
you have one person out earning the
other to the one it seems fair that one
person would contribute $1,000 a month
to the rent
and the other person would contribute
$500 a month to the rent okay so let's
start there now I mentioned non
usage-based if you go out to eat you are
basically paying for what you you do
choose to buy and thus I think it's more
of a discussion with going out to eat
like do you still want to split things
two to one two-thirds one-third or do we
say hey since we're going out and sort
of choosing what it is we want to order
and choosing how expensive the
restaurant is maybe you say well when we
go out to eat we split it evenly or
maybe not I have less of a strong
opinion on that another example would be
I don't know the electrical bill or
something a lot like that the electrical
bill is based on usage so maybe you say
well we'll split that evenly as opposed
to in proportion to our income I don't
know I think I know either way up
someone's at home a lot more maybe using
things that there are a lot more
electricity better enough to pay more
but I think generally I believe that it
is very very fair for couples to split
expenses in proportion to what their
incomes are and in addition to this I
want to go a step further I don't think
it's crazy for couples to maintain
personal bank accounts and then a shared
bank account that
used for shared expenses you don't have
to contribute to the shared bank account
equally you might determine your monthly
expenses or $2,000 so you are each going
to contribute a different amount maybe
it's one person contributes $1,200
towards the 2000 and monthly spending
and the other person contributes $800
towards the monthly spending you know I
have a friends in two situations when it
comes to couple spending some where one
person basically pays for nothing right
and typically in in modern Western
American society when that's the case
you've got a man that is earning more in
a heterosexual relationship with a woman
who is earning less in the friends that
I know and you some kind of situations
where the woman who sometimes is my
friend will say yeah you know my
significant other pays for everything I
kind of feel bad I don't really pay for
anything and yeah he makes more than me
but I still should be should be paying
some someone and I think that that's
where the paying in proportion to your
income makes a lot of sense the other
situation I'm aware of is where people
split everything despite the fact that
there are very unequal incomes and that
I also think is not necessarily fair and
I think it also is not that great for
the couple in the sense that if you have
one person in a relationship that makes
a lot more money than the other the
access to for example vacations that
that couple might have if they shared
the expenses of the vacations in
proportion to their income they might be
able to do a lot more vacationing than
if they go in saying we're only going on
vacation we can both afford 50% of the
cost there definitely also seems to be a
difference when you talk about the
initial phases in a relationship say
you're on your first couple days or if
when you're courting the other person
right is when you're in a
well-established relationship and I
think that's when gender roles come in a
lot more to play because typically in
the United States I mean the man is just
expected to pick up the bill at the end
of a dinner or if you go out for drinks
or something like that
especially when it comes to the first
few dates now what's fascinating about
that is I talked to more and more women
who say oh I did not allow him to pay
for the first date because I'm not
trying to establish anything where
there's an expectation so even though
it's not that I'm on many women have
told me it's not that I'm uncomfortable
with someone taking me out but it's the
first date and I don't want to set the
tone that I would even remotely expect
to be played paid for and so I know more
and more women that will go out of their
way to either pay on the first day or at
least to split the bill on the first
date but yeah you're talking more in
this initial courtship phase yeah versus
in the sort of longer term relationship
mode out because I think that you know
the man in that instance may feel like
the state has gone so swimmingly and
things are going great but I can't ruin
it by not offering to pay the entirety
of the bill because just that's the
customs that we have in this country I
don't know about others and you know you
don't want to break that norm even
though that may be the right thing to do
now that is a sexist by its very
definition
norm right I mean you agree with that
Mary yes categories all right everybody
make a note Leila
that's my answer do you think I will get
hate for this probably it regardless of
how you answer this question you're
going to get hate because either you're
splitting things up in equitably or you
are taking a sexist approach I would say
okay fair enough you're going to get
hate all right well regardless I'm ready
for it bring it on folks